merci la parole est à madame laurence
arribagé c'est l'oubli en échange de
questions merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre la crise
migratoire actuelle est en passe de
devenir l'un des plus grands échecs
humanitaire nos sociétés modernes
il est temps d'y apporter une réponse
concertée durable et non démagogique
au nom des milliers de réfugiés en
détresse il est de votre responsabilité
de dépasser les postures politiciennes
afin d'être à la hauteur des attentes de
nos concitoyens en matière d'humanisme
et de solidarité certes mais également
en matière de faisabilité et de moyens
dès lors je déplore la faiblesse votre
gestion des suite du démantèlement de la
jungle de calais faisant l'impasse sur
la notion élémentaire de dialogue votre
majorité impose à des mères consterné
des décisions de relogement soudaine et
trop souvent irresponsables
en l'absence de conditions structurelles
sociales et financières minimum requise
loin de jeter les bases d'une
collaboration en bonne intelligence
vos tentative de passage en force ne
font que crisper les élus locaux et les
habitants qui s'oppose alors à juste
titre à ses installations improvisée de
centres d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile
un mois garonne par exemple le maire de
saint gaudens a préféré suspendre le
contrat de ville de sa commune plutôt
que d'obtempérer à l'implantation d'un
centre décidé sans consultation de ses
services dans un périmètre qui juge est
inapproprié pourtant les municipalités
sont prêtes à participer à l'effort
national
aussi je condamne l'obstination de vos
ministres qui se contentent d'asséner
les discours moralisateurs
plutôt que d'offrir un accompagnement
adapté aux communes ces méthodes vous
mèneront au devant d'un échec prévisible
aussi monsieur le premier ministre
comment comptez-vous recréer la
confiance avec les maires de france
indispensable à la mise en place de
solutions pérennes
face à cette crise migratoire sans
précédent tout cela bien sûr en tenant
compte des réalités de nos collectivités
je remercie mes fils à paroles est un
monsieur bernard cazeneuve minisère
l'intérieur des députés nous venons
de réaliser deux grosses opérations
humanitaires une première opération
humanitaire à calais il y avait à calais
près de 7500 migrants qui pour 85% entre
relever du droit d'asile en france
nous les avons accueillis dans lequel du
démantèlement de la jungle de calais y
compris d'ailleurs les mineurs isolés au
sein de 460 centre d'accueil et
d'orientation
je suis allé à calais hier pour
remercier l'ensemble des services de
l'état qui se sont mobilisés sous la
responsabilité de la préfète fabienne
buccio pour remercier les associations
mais pour remercier aussi madame la
députée l'ensemble des préfet et
l'ensemble des maires qui ont accepté
d'accueillir sur leur territoire des
centres d'accueil d'orientation et je
veux profiter de cette séance des
questions au gouvernement
pour remercier chaleureusement ses
maires de france qui ont donné le plus
beau visage de notre pays en acceptant
d'accueillir ce qu'il veut relever de
l'asile en france
et ces maires de france ont donné une
image exemplaire très loin des discours
tenus par certains qui préconisait qu'on
mobilise à la population contre les
préfets alors même que nous cherchons à
organiser cette opération humanitaire
donc le beau visage de la france c'est
celui de ces mères que je veux ici
vraiment chaleureusement remerciés il y
en a d'ailleurs de toute sensibilité
alors il est possible madame la députée
qu'ici ou là il y ait eu des problèmes
et si ces problèmes remontés ne
manqueront pas de remonter nous
procéderons à des corrections mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que cette
opération s'est passé dans des
conditions exemplaires grâce à la
mobilisation de tous et grâce notamment
à la mobilisation des maires qui ont
donné le plus beau visage de la
république et de la france
merci monsieur le ministre